okay for those who are joining our
livestream this is an internal designer
view meeting about financial data feeds
for from language we have for a long
long time had whoops what happened here
um had wonderful internal capabilities
for
all data and what we are talking about
here is having capabilities that make
use of external services so for example
we right now I think you can say things
like I don't know you could say
something like Apple oh yeah financial
entity we could say ups not Prince but
price and that should get us the Oh what
is that its last price yeah no that's
not right
what is it we're waiting for some
changes to hit production to sync that
up with financial data because you are
not using financial data right now
you're going to entity value ah
so okay so this is so if I just ask for
the ongoing synchronizing alpha with the
language okay but so if I do this and
then I do dated of this comma all for
example I should get a time series right
of there we go
10000 points which I can then say date
let's plot and I'll see some spectacular
growth here I think in the case of this
particular there we go Wow it's
impressive actually it's not in recent
times it's not exponential it's just
linear um
one of the okay so what this is about is
making explicit use of third-party
providers to get both properties that we
already have and many other properties
right so there's primarily bloomberg and
Reuters is that correct that's correct
the property is really are unique
today they're all subtly different so
you it's a bit hard to really come maybe
last price but as Jason will tell us
there's there are subtle differences
between the definitions of these
properties as the properties are really
scoped to the provider that's the thing
we decided quite a long time ago we
can't to aggregate compare the concept
of the you know property across provider
turn off turn off we're not trying to do
that in other words we're just taking
there or if somebody ranked Bloomberg
property for such-and-such we are
transferring that through okay so does
somebody want to give a demo here before
we get so the issue so you could open
their a pre-prepared example here okay
well that's not an example that's a
bunch of things about SSL right well
that is because this one here doesn't
doesn't need to set up a connection it
just uses HTTP to a server
education where do you give your
credentials your Bloomberg credentials
you you don't you you install a
certificate on your machine that's how
it works
I see and that's something do we have a
workflow describing how to do that or
does all this point into Bloomberg's
workflow that describes how to do that I
think we should have one like that so
let's let's make a action item to
prepare one okay which mostly will point
to the Bloomberg documentation I would
assume well yeah I mean you get the I
dunno but I don't know if was really
documented but they provide when you get
the service in Bloomberg they give you a
personal certificate view certificate
can somebody explain that to me in terms
of HTTP yes so Bloomberg will give the
client a client certificate and we will
present this certificate to the
Bloomberg servers killing them we are
who we are is exactly the opposite of
the certificate that Bloomberg prisons
or any HTTP web site presents and then
we verify if the host is who the host is
so it's a two-way handshake and where
does that certificate get lodged in our
system our keychain you use keychain
assistant leader system keychain yes
that's what the text says in the
Bloomberg data license okay so you put
it in the system keychain and then then
when an HTTP request is made by us
Bloomberg is going and somehow I don't
even know exactly how that would work
going and querying that certificate is
that correct yes how do they
so Bloomberg is going to make a say SSL
handshake protocol okay and Bloomberg
will ask for client certificate and we
present a certificate so in other words
our so women from our side our server it
is asking the thing that connects to
them is being asked for the certificate
we are then going to the keychain to
pick up the certificate is that right
yes okay fine all right let's take a
look here handling these difficulties a
big part of what the team has been doing
over the past seems like a good thing to
to work with right is it relevant to
other services is there something we
should generalize yes
so yes it's a way of authentication is
kind of analogous to OAuth 2 or auth
where everything works through the head
is here it works over SSL yeah so when
you say so when we have a security
education key in our authentication
system by the way somebody's making
background noise good if you stopped
then um when when we have our secure
authentication key right which I would
assume is now so are you saying this is
a new form of secure authentication key
or is this something different it's a
very old way of authenticating
let's say SSL handshake protocol but we
do not have any language specification
for this involved from language no I
understand we don't now but I'm asking
you would it fit into the secure event
yes so in other words instead of what we
right now are supporting is OAuth only
and this would be another type of
security education key which would be
SSL handshake yes right yes okay
overhead to producing these certificates
I think there are services that will
create a certificates for that but with
Bloomberg is just a file that you
present when you're connecting you're
saying it's an old form of
authentication I mean it's Bloomberg the
unique example of the place where we run
into this or other other one no I
believe coinbase is another one the new
blockchain and Bitcoin I don't really
understand all that but from coins eyes
is a nice fresh new company so right but
they use client certificates okay for
education can we could somebody here
let's see who should deal with this
okay we have a question from our our
livestream saying I assume you're
talking about storing the root
certificate parens certificate authority
I do not understand that question does
somebody here understand that question
what certificate III think we're just
talking about a particular SSL
certificate not the underlying one right
I think we're just talking about the
specific certificate that will be issued
for this particular HTTP connection is
that correct for him yes okay um so okay
who here can go find out whether I mean
I guess Christian knows about the
coinbase case and the service connection
cases this is some they see whose does
anybody else here know about that oh I
think somebody from sucide men would be
very useful with whoever does our HTTP
stuff or web group I know about the
service connections but not coinbase in
particular okay do you know about can we
see if we can find can we ask Warren who
would be an appropriate person to talk
about this here Eric here
then must be here Ben could you make a
note of it no no why don't we actually
ask Warren right now why isn't somebody
go up and ask Warren who the appropriate
person is our person on the livestream
is saying but a web server cannot query
your key store yes indeed that is
correct there is a what my understanding
is that there is a on our side this
connection is brokered through something
that is it's that it which is not a web
server which is querying the key store
is that right for him yes it is we who
query because we know we are going to
Bloomberg and we have registered in the
key chain that when it is Bloomberg
asking give it this particular
certificate server itself cannot do
anything is the client who is taking the
actually this is toll this is a feature
of curl and we didn't make this up this
is this is curl that's interacting with
the key chain all right all right not
100% on Windows it is true on Linux it
is true on OSX it's not 100% true on OSX
we tell curl we use a bit of our code
and then provide the certificate to Cole
and then Cole takes over from there so
there's there's just one small step but
yes
okay all right let's go let's go insects
you start looking at content here so
Lumbergh data license why is it licensed
that's a very weird I'm I mean that that
is an entity that is a Bloomberg entity
your custom entity this is what
Bloomberg call it but bloomer data
license I mean that's kind of weird it's
a custom Bloomberg entity obtained
through the Bloomberg data license is
that correct yeah right and and then it
is being it is the P X underscore last
property Bloomberg named yes yes okay so
so Alan I mean in our entity naming
scheme what would we call this entity
what should we call the Saturday I mean
usually it's called something like you
know financial financial instrument or
it's called something like I think we
sure I mean it this is not this this
entity is not a Bloomberg data license
you know usually that the type is would
be the how you complete the sentence
this thing is a yeah what so what is
this thing this thing is a blank what's
the blank basically a ticker standard
name what this is I mean it's not that
part is but not this part these are both
Bloomberg entities of some kind px lost
an MX of T right technically in
Bloomberg they identify everything even
down to their personal email accounts a
ticker just because it's the way they
run I see well okay so then
let's see if I'm if I'm looking at I'm
just looking at the blog website here
comprehensive data by the way we've got
some background noise here um blah blah
blah blah he's and modern web protocols
except you guys say it isn't so modern
but who's to know um could we could two
hours making background noise please try
to fix that um could you try to fix that
please well this isn't helping us really
data content sets
you
so what should this be called this is a
this is a property of a Bloomberg well I
guess the entity property thing here
would be like in the usual case would be
financial instrument
for the entity but the energy property
no no but the entity property goes with
the entity so it is a property of a
financial instrument for example but
what is the what is the analog of the
word instrument for a bloomberg watt a
bloomberg entity it's an entity that is
a bloomberg what well in this case it's
the thing which has a price which is not
the company it's the security but that's
not going to be true for every entity
they have there's a lot of energies
which are just indicator time series
like the CPI or something which is a
natural traded instrument okay so what
is the difference between Bloomberg data
licence and Bloomberg terminal they're
different technologies so Bloomberg
terminal is sort of real-time entity is
not a Bloomberg terminal but well but
but the point is that we just got to
come up with a consistent name here um
Alan helped me out it what your
suggestions like Bloomberg financial
instruments or Bloomberg I'm not sure
because I don't I don't know what all
the different things are that there's it
the worry is they're not going to be
unique great I mean if you they they
need to pair here
Bloomberg data license MSFT US equity
will return some incorrect Ubu terminal
MSF to US equity correct correct right
okay oh gosh
well so there should be a noun at the
end of this that is you know Bloomberg
data licensed instrument are pretty
horrifying can't type it in well and
it's a
it'll autocomplete presumably sure
Bloomberg terminal instrument it sounds
like one of those things that you know
my shoe is ringing kind of thing um but
it's probably accurate or inaccurate
checker would also be inaccurate but
only in their particular case tickler is
really a wid thing I agree sounds like a
that that is another my shoe is ringing
kind of people would expect that to just
be MSFT at that point so yes um okay so
let's plan on Bloomberg data licensed
instrument Bloomberg tonight it's the
same thing because that's associated
with that okay do we have do we have any
chance of auto completion for any of
these things or are you kind of on your
own with that no it's just Bloomberg
give us a big table of things that we
can use for autocompletes
I mean for the for the ticker Center
names yeah for these things and that the
names possible but it depends that their
their license they may not provide that
they may not provide a complete
collection people can be very you know
concerned about that concern but the
fact that we can use their API to
download that on a client per client
basis that is okay I say all right fine
so so we could in principle cash if
people really care we could cash in
autocomplete table in the client at the
client yes we don't have to yes okay so
the autocomplete framework that's still
under development for cases like this
would presumably be used here but so
let's let's make that Bend that's
something for you that's something we
should be worrying about in the future
we probably won't have the on version
one okay it's been here
yes I'm here good okay so that brace is
unnecessary right
am i correct that would require
for Alan but Alan I think very what's
what's unnecessary
sorry brace around the date attribute
here
it should not be required ok is this
frame look are you using the modern
entity store framework or using
something else to deal me I'm using the
custom entity developed by Tony that's
what's ok it's Tony here yes and you
okay so Tony if that brace needed it's
not Nina ok good related work around the
entity property yes it's just an alias
for this longer entity property ok
notice that user assistance failure of
that reddening has been reported before
ok all right
a hundred and fifty seconds is an
outrageously long time what is it doing
going out and getting carrier pigeons to
get the information in yes in a way I
was right to started off with carrier
pigeons in the nature of the data
license so it's not real time obviously
but it has lots of historical data
basically you and unique data points
that's it's really a small amount of
data how could it take so we cook that
because we only ask for a small amount
of data so I see so that hundred and
fifty seconds is Bloomberg kind of
deciding it's going to send the data and
then sending the data or that's US
making two hundred and sixteen requests
or something no no no that the data
really did take you know it wasn't there
until you know is that a 150 seconds
later so this is I would submit this is
why the submit version of this is much
more useful why is it so slow
I mean Bloomberg tunnels in general are
not slow no no so here's my own mutant
no no okay so what is happening is that
we are actually making quite a few calls
but the first request is Bloomberg has
acknowledged the request the subsequent
requests are
is the data ready so we are polling and
normally it takes two minutes for data
to be available and when the data is
available we get that data that's weird
okay fine why is that maybe something to
do with their later license yes dapi
yeah okay so it's gonna take two minutes
okay so that is the answer yes so right
okay
very weird but that's that's the answer
okay um that's why this next version is
what we called scheduled service submit
in the last meeting is more useful
okay well let's come to that in a minute
I think Warren just joined us and
actually somebody from our live feed is
making the comment connection to
Bloomberg is encrypted using a mutually
authenticated SSL session
I think that's isn't that that's
accurate that's precisely what it is
that's what we were talking about
initially okay so hey Warren uh you here
I'm here okay so this is we're talking
about the the way that our Roth secure
authentication key that represents all
the authentication for connections and
we're talking about this ssl certificate
based authentication mechanism that
involves storing maybe somebody can
explain for him do you want to explain
yes so when we are connecting to
bloomberg we have to present client
certificate that bloomberg has provided
to us to tell them that we are who we
are and so I believe client certificate
is stored in the keychain for that
particular user is that right yes so you
can't do it on a site-wide basis it's
stored on a per-user basis is that right
if you're asking me typically if well we
do this internally where we have things
that connect to other stuff for example
on our internal test and development
boxes we have a local certificate
authority that signs things and we just
install that SSL cert into both you know
Tomcats keychain and the system keychain
so when we connect to any you know
development services that don't need a
real outside SSL cert but one just
assigned internally then we
automatically trust that because we've
installed that root certificate on the
machine and in Tomcats key store so it
knows hey anything that is using the
internal certificate authority any sign
by that we know to trust okay so how
does that relate to for him how does
that relate to the stuff you've done
with keychain which sounds like those
are user key chains not something like a
tomcat sheets you know so what Warren is
talking about internally signed
certificates but this is a client
that the company has to provide
specifically to us and that lives in the
key chain in a particulars key chain
right there is system-wide key chain
know it is a system wider as a non
machine yes but it's not like Enterprise
sort of a key okay but I mean but if if
like I log out of my machine and you
know my cat if I had one logged into my
machine it would not get the same
keychain material right it depends on
how you have installed it Bloomberg does
not make any restrictions on that part I
say right you can have a user you know
will keep a certificate that a user
trusts but the system does not obviously
anything that the system trusts a user
just by an area okay all right so what
was the question here for Warren it had
to do with generalizing secured
authentication key to deal with these
SSL cert based authentication is that
right was that what we what we wanted to
discuss was it something else
well is this a model that we could be
using in other technology we could be
using in other places somebody said that
coinbase had a some similar connection
mechanism but it sounds like we we think
we know okay you know the question is
how would we do top-level a top level
design for secure authentication key
that is making because right now with
the OAuth stuff I don't even know yeah I
think this is a separate discussion we
should we should get on with the
financial data discussion I don't
separate discussion I think we can we
can break this off and have if if Fahim
can package that code so that it is
generalizable then we can try and figure
out how to I mean we should look at the
one other case of coinbase if you think
that that really is another case does
anybody know of other services that
require these client certificate things
No
okay let's break that off and separately
talk about that I mean what Fahim has
done is build this into our link to curl
that is the base of our you know sort of
URL you know sort of execute and you
know type function okay so it's totally
transportable to other URL you know HTTP
HTTPS type time transfer well fine but
we need a top level design for it do we
understand what that would be thought um
person person on a live stream is asking
I assume the client here is the wolfram
server performing a host host request
instead of being a user's browser
absolutely it is the it is Wolfram
language code it's the Wolfram language
system that is acting as a client
interacting with the external in this
case Bloomberg server correct people
yeah I had a damn wolfram server it is
not Wolfram server it is the client
right it's about language client so
actually that raises a question does
this stuff is this stuff going to work
in the cloud yes it can work yes
certificate hold on the virtual machine
which it can be limit that you're
talking your answering for a private
cloud Tom that correct okay so what
you're saying is in a private cloud one
could have you know we have a bunch of
customers in the finance area who
definitely care about this one could
install that would be kind of a nice
thing one could install it would be a
Bloomberg in centrally in the private
cloud and where would one install that
one we would just go to the virtual
machine that is the private cloud and go
and stall the stuff with our
configuration correct stuff right and
then but now for our public cloud that's
hopeless right we can't do it no we
cannot fine
okay um so that's a great distinguishing
feature of our private cloud dependent
you do yes indeed but in order to make
that work in the private cloud do we
need features from beyond does I don't
even understand how a keychain would
work that that's some kind of system
keychain that happens to be running in a
virtual machine yes on Linux separate
VPK SEO tell you just give their
certificate and it will install it in
the correct place okay but again so what
does it look like when you call when you
make a call which is basically a URL
execute call it has an authentication
option and the authentication option
says basically this will use the SSL
certificate with such-and-such a name to
make this request is that correct not
quite the way we have done it it is done
automatically that is from Wolfram
language perspectives there is zero code
and because we know that when you're
making a request I mean the Bloomberg
you know connection is ultimately a just
a random URL is that correct
it's not just a random URL it's a
specific endpoint all the requests go
through this tab but it's a specific
endpoint bloomberg.com slash whatever
yes right okay so for that particular
URL you are in some way knowing that
when you make a request there then and
the request you're making is somewhere
deep inside the entity store inside the
code that implements the entity store is
that right yes okay to do that at a more
top level where we to do that in a more
raw way we will be calling URL execute
with an authentication table
yes that's exactly right if you wanted
to give any kind of random certificates
yes you would be doing it and right so
all I'm saying then is that we should
just have a case of security
authentication key that says instead of
or just says the name of the SSL
certificate that we're trying to use
that potentially isn't printable okay
Warren any further comments on this I
don't think so
okay thanks for your help yeah no
problem
see you the UM okay let's get back to
the asynchronous case here so what
you're doing here oh my gosh this is all
pretty horrifyingly complicated Wow
yesterday I know I suggested it was a
lot less complicated than the previous
version yeah submit functionality okay
so what is a the scheduled service
submit
is an analogue why is it not called
service submit
because it's why is it why is it not
just service submit well that's a
question I think we did call it that at
one time I see that one chance right so
sometimes there is a there is a calendar
option in there as well I think there's
an example of that okay but but but so
this is the analog as service executes
is serve as soon as URL executes is the
URL submit correct it certainly could be
yes okay so let's take a look at URL
submit and remind ourselves what that
read there's there's one minor
distinction and that's that service
executes internal they serve two layers
there's the raw response and then
there's the cooked response and so
typically service executed you know
underneath there is a URL read or URL
submit depending on if it's synchronous
or asynchronous and it gets back the
that raw JSON or so what Jeff I'm at but
then but then a structures into data set
or something interesting sure you're
talking about so when you're talking
about the callback functions when we're
talking about what we wanted with the
callback functions we're gonna want
either the cooked values or the raw
values or some super extension obviously
right but but so what I would assume and
the only issue is how lazy it is in the
computing of these things what I would
assume is that some of the keys yeah in
fact we have a very good mechanism for
doing this because we have a handler
function keys option that tells us which
handler functions are going to be asked
for right which keys are going to be
asked for so basically what we should do
is we should have a set of keys
including we should have the raw JSON
you should be able to get the raw JSON
if you really wants it right and then
you should have cooked versions of those
keys that can have you know that we just
make a list of them basically that goes
down right to the level of
you know war response right one possible
key but the names it will not
necessarily line up here body of course
not of course not absolutely not those
are business for an HTTP request right
and if we have something for that rod
Jason you know one cooked request might
actually make multiple requests so it
could give a list in general you know
well I don't know stand that comment I
mean III write if you remember like the
social media where we make those graphs
yeah friendships you know you're making
ten calls compiling so if you if you
want that Rogerson it's not gonna be one
JSON object I see well maybe we talk I
mean in other words what you're saying
is what raw JSON you get depends on
you're saying for every query you might
get a piece of raw JSON right look over
one service execute or service submit
there will be multiple queries in
general
I understand I mean this question about
whether you even want the raw JSON I
mean we might as well provide it but
then we just want a law version of each
of the queries which would bring back or
a JSON version of each of the queries
which would bring back a list of JSON
objects or JSON strings rather than
bringing back the the fully cooked
version yeah
I agree it is a natural extension it's
just a little there's a can of worms or
two in there okay well we maybe don't I
mean okay so let's take a look at this
in the initial form okay so service
submitters the potential name for this
but there's you're claiming that there's
a scheduling aspect to it we certainly
don't have a URL submit with scheduling
the only scheduling we have is a
scheduled task object which gets
scheduled right but this is an
externally scheduled task where you're
telling the Bloomberg server to go and
you know respond with this result every
Monday morning type thing is that
correct you you can certainly do that
yes yes exactly
okay okay an example if you scroll down
you'll see it okay but but okay but
let's take a look here this is the a
load of this two service execute is okay
so the service whoops I don't mean that
I mean service execute service I guess
is here Bloomberg data license that's
the correct name for the service it's a
pretty weird name but anyway whatever if
that's what they want to call it that's
what they and then
let's see and then I mean I assume we
have been communication it's a separate
meeting and separate discussion but I
assume we have actually been in
communication with the folks at
Bloomberg about this and how to how to
make sure that that um
they're the yeah the bad data license
yeah
documentation covers this etcetera
etcetera okay I'll assume that's all
under control okay um not not the issue
with we're addressing here but but now
okay so the typical thing is a service
and a request and then a bunch of
parameters okay so okay so are there any
other requests to Bloomberg data license
other than lookup no okay we talked
about this we brought everything into
just look up okay it seemed more natural
okay um yeah it's a little funky that
you have to put the word look up there
it sounds very much you know it's like
an incantation
um right right alright but it is not the
only incantation in this business hmm
okay so handler functions task status
changed okay result received is the main
thing that right you want as a handler
function why on earth we having ok
schedule of one-shot is that's the
default for a service submit right yes
yes okay so the result where did it come
come back with that result
okay so the result received is an
association that looks like this is that
correct yes that's what we thought of
doing yes mm-hmm
I mean I don't quite
understand if there's going to
ultimately be a value why not have a
hash value thing that just is the value
that can come back here I mean why do I
have to go you know hash evaluation
result of quotes value to get the value
if the thing is always gonna bring back
one value and the rest of it is just
telling you what you asked for
it might be very useful to know what you
asked for but ultimately what you want
is the value that comes back right
probably yes well it depends on you have
a bunch of asynchronous result things I
see I see the problem is because this is
asynchronous you actually don't know
what you asked for
when the thing comes back well you you
could always encode that information in
the handler function that you have there
could could have you know it we're
assigning into a variable we could
assign it to a different variable yeah
yeah no sorry I don't like having
Richard results is useful I think I
understand but we can provide multiple
keys here we affirm for servanthood yeah
in general for services were not stingy
with adding requests so he could have
latest value and latest data as
different names in the lookup instead of
look up instead of lookup well is it
always called value and is it always
latest value or just value
it will be value and it would be what
would this be it wouldn't be called data
what what were the right name for this
whole thing here Association well when
this is going to finish this is like the
end of the one shot so this is kind like
a result
what is the result the value is the
result you've got a society calling it
value arey calling it result what my
person let me get it fine
what I'm saying is that when this has
come it came to terminate going to exit
I agree what's your point right no so
what I mean it's not like later
it couldn't be something like later I
know you know I don't think that's the
right idea don't you want
I I'm gonna suggest value and response
and response is the complete thing here
is that reasonable I'm not sure if
that's reasonable um-hmm what will be a
good way to describe this whole thing
well ok preliminarily let's call it
let's say value in response let's see
how that flows in other places right hmm
I would sort of prefer to call it
results given that it's bringing back
something like a time series which is
hardly a value agreed values are
definitely technical meaning inside the
payload what does px last mean last
price finally follow that it's a
Bloomberg symbol there's nothing to do
with that that's the particular thing
you requested here this is a whole I
guess all right for any proper result
the only question is what is this whole
I mean we could call it request reserve
what should we call it so we're going to
require that they tell us what property
they want we're not going to have
pre-built requests for given properties
we always have they always have to tell
us the property look look look look here
okay first point is yes we're not going
to this lookup thing is always just one
in incantation but it's it's the it's
the you know in some weird you know
magical spell thing it's the it's the
thing you say to make something happen
okay and then the actual Bloomberg name
and properties stuff I don't know other
other things you can put in here in
addition to name and property sure it
could be specifications like date ranges
and okay so that's part of the Bloomberg
world but with the left hand side is
determined by us right
yeah I'm just thinking for other service
connections we've taken like the most
basic thing that people are gonna want
to make and made it just don't worry
about in this case this is a complicated
world people wants very specific
bloomberg queries okay um but what we do
need to know is what the other left hand
sides are here I think named property
and date are there any other
no I'm not I'm not sure there's anything
else - he what the API do that's that's
all there is because we covered Tech
Data and we also covered yeah
everything can be covered under property
okay so if you see historical data how
we have done that we interpreted using
interval right okay some from the live
stream is suggesting how about response
object for the name of the thing
unfortunately it's not well we would
usually call that like an HTTP response
is a is an object but this is just a
naked association with no head around
right um I mean in the case of if this
was an import thing this would be called
rules using the somewhat old-fashioned
name right that would be when you do
import but that is a common
also values of all elements but that's
that's because we didn't have
associations in those days yes that's
true
so I kind of think results association
is okay I wish it could we'll say
something about the request as well the
modern way in entity property is calling
it entity property association and such
Tony do you want to comment on that is
that an entity property Association I
don't think it is particularly an entity
property Association has entity as keys
and at a lower level properties of keys
right so this is not that this is a and
I you know the fact that this is says
service hmm I'm I'm still thinking
results association though I don't like
it very much let's keep going here okay
so all of these were one shots you said
there's something other than one shot
that's a possibility
yes team do we have any examples of that
I want to go on and look at the other
ones here okay so right so in our case
of of Oh what's this
right now the Reuters and number
terminal yeah we need to specify a
connection some sort of connection thing
and they're all kind of different so we
need we need some potential firm so I'm
totally confused here so this is right
this is now a pure entity store this is
not using any kind of service submit or
anything like that no there should be an
example of this these with sells it with
service submit yes except now it's going
through the Bloomberg terminal
technology okay so the Bloomberg
terminal technology is comparable to the
Bloomberg data license technology is
that correct what's the difference why
would in B's one rather than the other
terminal isreali yes yes I see
so is Terminal much more often used in
this non submit type mode yes okay
and whereas Bloomberg data license is
I'm going to look up a historical data
you know Bloomberg's probably collected
everything all the way back yeah that's
that's right
I see look at the Reuters Bloomberg
terminal slightly newer let's look under
the Reuters and look at those right so
here we've got to submit right here
we've got yet another connection
technology and then look under submit
okay so those are we need a way to make
a war connection that was some law
connection thing that was specified
there that that where you're given those
things I hope those weren't real numbers
no and you have to have a special box to
get that you won't be able to do it
otherwise
so I can look at this and nobody's going
to abscond with these numbers no no they
can't do it they okay so what on earth
is this yeah you have to sort of set all
this stuff for connecting to the VPN box
that they ship to you right let me give
you some hardware they give you some
network hardware boy okay
well it's better than the actual old
times when they used to install an
actual physical terminal for a Bloomberg
terminal yes okay it's just it's now
reduced to a single box rather than the
full suite and everything it makes a
nice technology for all that stuff I
think but yeah okay so all right we need
it function by the way so can your
workflow documentation that explains how
to get all those numbers and how to type
them in from presumably Reuters sends
you yes yes and yes of those things and
then you just have to copy them out to
here yeah correct yes right you know I
would think so grass is good right well
if it's bringing back a so in a minute
the service connect is giving you
something which can ultimately which is
then an entity store so how did don't
you have to register the entity store
after that how is it registering the
entity store when you do a service
connect then it is registering the
entity store in the background okay is
that what is that the way we want it
Tony
mechanism are you using custom entities
I mean there is a hidden internal
mechanism to register things and there's
a public mechanism the operations
village will it show up in entity stores
open closed or not
and entity stores open closes like is
only custom entities is that true
it doesn't include our internal entity
stores correct
okay I'm using the public one
what do you mean by public when you mean
that the custom one for users yes custom
one for the users yes I think it's okay
if this shows up in the because I can
imagine people wanting to get rid of
that entity store to disconnect from
Reuters for example for some reason I
who knows maybe there's some billing
that's based on time or something they
want to disconnect so I don't see a
problem with it showing up in the actual
entity stores open closed list anybody
else anybody disagree with that no okay
fine all right
so then this should now say presumably
Reuters ETA instrument correct and the
name of the service is Reuters ETA but
the name of the entity type is Reuters
ETA instrument makes sense to people yes
um oh I do love the way these are Baha
well that's where we add value with our
financial data stuff as it's all nice
wrong normalized and you don't have to
know all of these different ticker
convention correct um everything else of
course that was a lot of work um correct
okay so what's this now so this is now
you're gonna show me the entity property
Association for that fine
I mean that's the standard entity
property Association that comes to the
entity framework right entity store
framework true statement yes yes yes he
didn't write any code to make that work
look how the currencies all work out
isn't that nice no I mean no James they
come from oh you mean we did that we did
that yeah okay get them back numbers
okay
well that's much nicer um let's talk
about the exchange mapping how are we I
mean if they change if they add the UM I
don't know the Fijian I don't know
whether I doubt very much there's a
Fijian stock market but if there was or
if there started to be 102 varlyn stock
market are they going to I mean how do
we
get information on that so that we can
do the correct emergency thing what do
we think we really currently don't we
read it and we look it up against our
names so as long as it's an ISO code for
the currency we'll get it yes we'll get
it you okay right right but now those
entities I see I see I see this so these
are the names these are the pure Reuters
names for everything here it's kind of
fun correct we're seeing you know
basically because usually those names
will be our common names that you see in
the yellow box see what I'm saying but
it isn't a common name here it's a
standard name that in fact is somebody's
weird alien standard name am i making
sense it's standard in the alien
universe no no but what I mean by that
is if you type in look if I were to type
in something like um you know if I type
in NYC right it's gonna say New York
City right but if I say what actually is
that its standard name is this
complicated thing here I'm saying I'm
sure if I type in something like you
know if I typed Alan Turing I'm sure
that will be the name that prints but
the name that is underneath there is you
know something with some weird code
after it right to unique apply it okay
so my question is when you're printing
AAPL that oh do you get is there another
query to Reuters to ask what the what
the common name of that company is yes
yes that is it's basically common name
or name yeah but now there's a question
for Jason and I think Michael Kelly is
also on the call for the users of this
are they going to want to see the
tickers or are they gonna want to see a
common name there they probably want to
see the tickers because the common names
are not unique that way I see um
alphabet Google
Berkshire Hathaway muscle multiple share
classes same common name okay all right
and I mean like the dot o is that it's
that a generic class for Apple or
something no no that's just saying it's
over-the-counter that's just saying it's
a Nasdaq stock I see um and so and
that's the crazy Nippon Stock Exchange
thing where they for Tokyo that's right
um but and so the fact so I mean the
actual users the fact that that might be
you know NTT or something they don't
care they just know it as seven two six
seven
well different different people I mean
so people go different ways in that if
there's any possibility of ambiguity
about the name they don't want the name
but for most there isn't that should be
maybe we should be able to actually
display the name um you know as a you
know may not be nice to display the name
um
sure he talked over not the name that
would best best best both worlds for
most users but the point of view well
but what about displaying the name as a
paren possibly I mean Alan and Tony what
I mean right now you are simply
defaulting in this case normally the
display for an entity would go and query
the common name is that correct but if I
wouldn't take that AAPL dot oh it
doesn't have a common name no common
name has been assigned to that entity in
the custom entity framework how do you
deal with common name if you specify a
label that will be used to a device to
canonical name okay so you will hear B
be Apple right and but the actual
underneath right that's correct that's
that's look so now the question is in
terms of the display code um you know
what what would we like this to look
like if if you had the choice of what
this looks like by the way it also is
rather strange that you don't have
anything and I don't understand why this
is the case why doesn't it have a
they're after a peel Dada why doesn't it
say that told my own input isn't it
if you evaluated that New York City you
would just get oh yeah that's right okay
so I see so on input if I were to copy
this down on input this will have a
horrendous long blue Aegean story okay
well that's perfectly nice okay I mean
it's a little weird with the writers ETA
because all caps but that's perfectly
reasonable what that does okay
so Alan were we too want to disambiguate
what well we do want this thing here to
have some kind of indication of what the
common name is what will we do do we
have a grey parens tradition or telling
the subway a sub-label right Tony I mean
that's implemented in the custom entity
framework yes can you give me an example
of where we see that they sing converts
okay only only in only on current right
now that is totally weird I typed in the
word shoe thing that's a very weird
disambiguation that was extremely
straight okay but so what what are you
telling me that that if I said if I had
multiple word meanings I would see a
grey paren with the disambiguation of
the word meaning is that correct
I was just checking shoe so the the the
new entity type word sense uses uses sub
labels I don't think you're gonna you're
only can you can you put a something out
death mode right okay yeah one second I
can I can pull something sure okay but
then that would be the way around that
that is its is it is it is a word and
then it's disambiguation is in gray
parens as opposed to here where it's a
peeled a toe which is the disambiguation
and what we want to give us the common
name in some other form I mean I think
it would be nice
I don't know well finance folk can you
comment if it said APL that o paren
Apple or something I mean there is
presumably some fuller name for this
that says you know Apple common stock
Nasdaq over-the-counter common stock or
something yeah you don't really wanna
see that mean you want to see either
Apple or the tip over that your ticker
exchange at most fine what do we tick ER
and exchange so I mean like like you for
example for example if you have you know
a royal dutch/shell you want to know
whether or not you're getting the London
listing or the answer I see and what
about these things what are the 80 Oz
and things like that although yes the
thing for most cases if you if you're
getting the same company and you're
getting the u.s. 80 are you know it
you'll just know it because in York
Stock Exchange ticker but if you you
know you could easily have Toyota Motor
to Tokyo vs. Toyota Motor ADR so in
terms of making people not make mistakes
and things it's like it will be good to
give them some indication that 7 2 6 7
is whatever it is and yes or something
okay but it's probably not as important
to tell them the exchange because they
can plainly see that from the ticker
that a true statement as long as the
ticker form is being shown includes the
exchange which for Reuters it always
will you also do Bloomberg well these
are different convention about it but
there's some information about it so you
see MSX equity it's not telling you that
it's Nasdaq because they assume that you
know it because it's four letters its
Nasdaq but
right well that's okay that's alright
because that's a repeated thing I'm
anybody who's in the biz knows that
right um okay so Alan when you when you
get that's okay
so hey emailed a screenshot to you okay
okay
well it seems quite nice I mean to be
able to say that APL dato / an apple
seems pretty useful now do we have by
creating these these things do we have
the word Apple or does it come out with
a 16 word description of that particular
financial instrument if you're looking
for a common name it will just say Apple
Inc okay fine well that seems very
useful so framework folk how do we do
this Toni how would they do this and the
customers good framework so you specify
first a label then the sub label and
that's it okay so the label would
default to the standard name and then
the sub label they would give based on
the comment based on the retrieved
common name yes it so it should be able
to take a function as its yes you can
specify a function for most label and
sub label
okay that does still mean if you if you
applied common name to one of these
things
you're still gonna you're only gonna get
the label or yes effectively gonna be
the standard name right yes if you want
more detailed information you would
probably use entity value to clearly
label or the sub label fine
but we should probably have I mean you
know that's going down that this is
where we don't want to go because then
we're cooking every proper the Bloomberg
and everybody else provides we're not
doing that if they have a query that
gives you a name you know they may have
six different kinds of names um why am I
reminded of the TS Eliot practical cat's
name thing but anyway um for you know a
company has I don't remember how many
whatever um okay
all right what else do we have to figure
out here looks to me like we're okay oh
there's the case we haven't seen yet
okay so so for finance folk here um
what oh wow that's in Jersey pounds
that's exotic um these these properties
they just are what they are there's
nothing we can really do they're just
whatever the bloom Bogle writers
properties are we're just gonna give
them here right there's no reason to
annotate that in any way I agree okay
okay alright so looks like we have one
more thing to look at which is this
continuous scheduled thing whatever that
means
right this is a way of streaming
real-time data okay and so we wanted to
know what the right naming conventions
for all of these things which I think
that's different from a submit I mean a
submit is a fire-and-forget type thing
well is it you can submit her you can
submit a scheduled you know something to
go on a schedule so whenever you know
the schedule satisfied it does something
yes it's going to trigger so they're
similar to session submit of a scheduled
tasks
I believe walk me through that so wait a
minute what how does a continuous tasks
and I don't think anybody in this
meeting is an expert on continuous tasks
but can you it's a really just like
scheduled tasks that just keep running
well you can say that right but I'm
trying to understand in terms of the
submit mechanism for a continuous task
you're saying okay so in a private cloud
you can say cloud submit or cloud deploy
of a continuous task right um the um so
okay so it seems to me
servus submit how would we do this so
because in a task what's in a session
submit what we're doing is we've got the
task specification wrapped all the way
around all the stuff that's inside here
whereas this is just an afterthought and
it's not an appropriate afterthought
because it really deeply affects what's
going on
right so let's take a look at the way
that sessions submit for example works
right so session submit here can take a
scheduled task with an expert a spec oh
this is a mess because an unsession
submit in principle could take a
continuous task that's not yet support I
think it probably won't but might not
make any sense but it could do yes well
local submit could take a continuous
task okay difficult it can yeah that
what's happening here is that session
submit is just being given a whorfin
language expression whereas service
submit is being given some weird request
to an outside service right battery so
bye-bye writes what we should be saying
is something like um service submit of
somebody is pointing out for our live
stream that scheduled service submit has
a typo in it um much which one yeah well
right under submit missing our before
the V in service oh yes so it is I hate
seeing those things um okay so session
submit so the issue is normally the
payload would be all packaged up right
so the payload and if the payload exper
is packaged up we can as well rewrap the
payload with a continuous task
see what I'm saying but we can't do that
here because in the service submit the
payload is not just is not singly
wrapped so to speak hump might suggest
there's something wrong with the way
we're doing this okay so the difference
so cloud evaluate would be the analog
okay so you are all execute doesn't have
the same issue because it's icy its
payload you only ever a one-off well we
don't have the possibility of a URL
submit that has a continuous task inside
it although that's not obviously wrong
in other words we do have client-side
refresh for URLs submit if I'm if I'm
explaining myself client-side submit of
continuous talk of URL execute yes I
agree but so the issue here is that what
we've what we've got to do we want to
represent um the UM it could be solved
by like a service request object that's
similar to HTTP requests objects okay
that's an interesting suggestion then
it's all wrapped up
that makes a lot of sense to me okay
so you're proposing that what would
happen is instead of that service submit
would generally have a service request
object inside it as a courtesy we might
allow this this exposed version right
but if you want to schedule it then
you're gonna have to use the object
right expose version it's only the one
off somebody is pointing out on our live
stream it seems like a non-obvious
API yeah this is absolutely horrendous
we're dealing with a jungle of outside
weirdness here if we were just inside
our own language it's very beautiful
um where we're trying to interface to
the the jungle of the outside world here
I think service request is a good way to
do this so in other words what we would
do is everything here would have um so
that would then have the service name
well as service executes yes although we
could in fact support something like
this which would make um you know
something of that kind that seems to be
a reasonable way to do it it's a fine
extension yeah um and then in the case
of thee and then what would happen is
that that's in the service request
although or you could just give service
in the request and then the properties
there then the parameters there right
yeah you have parameters right which is
exactly like what we get in a full URL
specification right in a full HTTP
request we've got here the scheme the
use of the domain blah blah blah and
this service request could contain
authentication information all kinds of
lovely stuff but then the full wrapping
would be service submit of continuous
tasks you can even it could even take a
service object
instead of a name for the service yes
that's right and that would contain the
authentication information in the object
in the service object right okay so
there's a service request that wraps a
service object so we've got three levels
here we've got the service submit which
contains all the handler functions and
things right those are the callbacks and
then we've got a service request which
is the packaging of the request that's
being made the continuous task or the
scheduled task which is controlling
under our control because that has
nothing to do well maybe we have to
translate our when the service submit
happens it has to translate our
scheduled task specification into let's
say a Bloomberg scheduled task is that
correct yes yeah have we already done
that what do you just suggested it so
nobody I mean I mean in terms of our
scheduled task specifications is that
non-trivial or is that trivial it is non
it'd be easier because Bloomberg don't
support an awful lot of I mean it's just
daily and weekly isn't it
that's all they support okay so what are
we talking about the continuous tasks
where you the detail from the Bloomberg
is always coming but we represent we
only present the data with the given
scheduled tasks verbage okay hold on
there are two different cases here
whoops
scheduled tasks which would be our which
has a schedule here right that scheduled
task is I mean I I feel bad show you all
the stuff if it's still good task always
we have to do this to interact outside
work so beautiful if we just do it with
our own internal stuff um
the schedule is is the service schedule
so it's not as rich a language of power
no I understand I understand so it's the
scheduled task by the way the answer to
on the question on the livestream about
continuous tasks a rapper
rather than being parameter to scheduled
tasks because continuous task is really
thought of in a different way it will be
running on some embedded device the
typical use case of a continuous task is
you have some random Raspberry Pi that's
running some image processing software
you just wanted to keep running forever
and you know when the thing reboots it
will keep running it just always keeps
running that's really what a continuous
task is in the in the you can and it's a
little bit different than a scheduled
task which says you know run at every
five minutes or something um but um okay
so what was the point is so continuous
tasks okay a scheduled task you say
Bloomberg supports certain scheduling x'
is that correct yes Bloomberg data
license not Bloomberg terminal they
don't support any scheduled tasks okay
so there would be like threatened
license right supports what daily and
weekly okay fine yes daily we've got
that so if you give anything else there
it's just gonna give an error correct
correct okay um okay and for continuous
tasks you're saying you are telling the
Bloomberg system to continuously stream
the data there is a question about how
often we actually call does it does it
call the function whenever the data
changes or do we have to specify how
often it calls the function it will only
have the callback functions whenever the
data is available it will call the
callback functions okay fine so it is
continuously calling the callback
functions it's not saying do it it's not
saying Paul every five minutes or
something no
there's no polling okay okay fine all
right
nothing else we have to figure out here
no I think this is quite I think I think
we've got to go back and do some
implementation I think we should do some
implementation can we write up we did
write up a documentation page but I
think there's any point can we go and
like knit in some other pages or if you
want the written what other pages well
we you know to get links into this or
should you know add things the guide
pages in tentative way or would you want
to little that I mean it is where do I
can look for this just do scheduled
service and met and you should have it
oh I see so submit I I thought you meant
so is it in the list of it's not yet in
the services list no it is the name of
the function okay only the function
thing so we've got scheduled service not
this I don't know legacy King but in
fact it might be exactly what we want
well maybe right we could I don't think
expression being evaluation is the right
thing at all because there's no
expression here unless you mean by that
the scheduled task if you mean by that
the the service request that's fine
that's what it should mean yeah well
then the evaluation result could be a
service response as a wrapper yeah it
could be it could be it could be why not
why not do it that way that the service
response is a fully wrapped thing like
an HTTP response and then the other
things you get are things like yeah I
mean if we did it that way then you
would always get that and if you want to
simply peel off the value you would make
a further query to peel off the value
we don't want service response as the
result from service execute though but
if you give a service request to service
execute the result should be a service
response surely look there's another
plan or Alexa Q it doesn't give her look
we've got this would you give it this
would look up which is just our random
incantation what we're really saying is
there are different cases here because
you might just want to get back the pure
value or you might want to get back this
whole response why not encode that
choice in that thing which otherwise is
a purely the still in contention by
making sense I see right so then what we
would do there is say let's see what we
would do is say something like I don't
know writers okay so what would it be it
would be what is the name of the request
so that let's imagine there were two
requests one gives back the service
service response object and one gives
back just the value we could say value
lookup versus what will be the
I'll give medic tasks right service to
make your spec a task it does but we're
defining in here the time before the
evaluation Explorer evaluation no no I'm
saying computer on these just keys the
things that come back no no yes the
things that come back are keys right but
that then you're leaving okay so what
you're saying is okay we've got two
kinds of keys running around okay we've
got the requests the initial requests
made to this particular service could we
love is making weird background noise
stop please the
okay so
then we've got
let's see the concern is something
called an evaluation expression would
have to be a a you know a constructed
service request because that's the only
reasonable thing that can be called an
expression but it's not even being
evaluated it's just the wrong name okay
because evaluation would be there's an
expression it is the unev a lighted form
now you evaluate you get back a results
right that's not what we want here so I
think it would be requests is the thing
that that is that right it would be
service request would be that name there
instead of the valuation expression that
wants to be service request
I mean URL submit doesn't have any of
these
I think the keys in your L submit only
relate to the output fine
there's no that there are no keys to
give the input
for that work
fair enough but okay so then service
response services yeah so service
response would be the full service
response yeah right and then we could
have service result which will be an
optional thing which in the case of
these types of things the value right
would be the value yeah yeah yeah okay
the fault result returned in the
returned from the request not no
defaults not the right word because that
suggests if it can't figure something
out it primary just be primary primary a
good word okay okay so expression form
of the original requests being made yeah
okay result all result or well service
response result from the request itself
result from the preferential must if
your victory silently the service
respond okay response from the request I
like that expression form of the
response from it response from the
request as a service response fine
object okay okay I think we've got some
things to work up on this right I think
we think this is a pretty good and this
should be renamed here to be serviced
submit and and this you know you should
move over the things here we wrote this
the last time you know months and months
ago when we were months ago right we'd
get it out by the way we need to finish
this indeed we do um okay great time can
you send that notebook to then yep no
team maybe and same well we'll go over
there tomorrow morning okay okay okay
yeah okay this was up for people on the
livestream this is a particular
grotesque piece of design here because
we're dealing with this outside jungle
it's really I mean I just it's
horrifying
um it's usually much more beautiful in
this um
right I mean this will be quite nice I
mean as as a way to do achieve this
functionality we're making use of the
symbolic structure of things like
service requests and so on um which is
fairly nice given given the horrors of
the fact that we're dealing with lots of
incompatible outside services and so on
um I'd say I'm sending it to bend for
him and who Tom okay okay that's thank
you thank you okay for everybody okay